as outrage grows over the ongoing
violence in the middle east
so too does pressure on the
international community to act
demonstrators gathered on tuesday
outside the building that houses
israel's mission to the u.n calling for
an end to the hostilities
while inside the u.n the palestinian
ambassador called on the security
council to speak
with one voice president biden has
finally called for a cease fire elevated
his rhetoric
did that give you any hope that today
coming out of the security council the
united states might have softened its
position a bit
on a statement are you seeing any
difference in their level of engagement
we sincerely hope that he can succeed
in his efforts with the efforts of
everyone else who is
involved in this endeavor to reach an
agreement on a ceasefire
as we speak anytime soon
our objective is to put an end to the
tragedy and the suffering of our people
the security council has met four times
in the course of eight days with norway
tunisia and china pushing to keep the
crisis in the spotlight
we have heard from president biden in
supporting the cease-fire
so that's
really something consistent with what we
are
proposing in the security council so
we hope that we can continue to work
together among all council members with
a good result
at the request of the arab group along
with the organization for islamic
cooperation
the general assembly will hold its own
emergency meeting on thursday
the united states continues to insist
it's working tirelessly with players in
the region to bring about an
end to the violence arguing that quiet
diplomacy
is more effective than a public
statement even as the calls for
action are getting louder kristin salumi
al jazeera the united nations